[Música]
vamos falar sobre inovação e renovação
em políticas das drogas para o qual
precisamos todo o time tente pra isso
preciso ir fazer um consistório tem que
ser necessário muito breve mas que vai
muito longe
fizemos primeiro que os homens e todas
as civilizações encontraram substâncias
da natureza são para manipulá lo assim e
sempre utilizaram portanto não há
sinalizações sociedade sem a utilização
de substâncias
essas substâncias têm uma característica
essencialmente que são capazes de quando
serão introduzidas determinada maneira
ingerida determinada maneira fazem com
que a pessoa sinta coisas de frente às
alterações na sua actividade que haja
alterações no seu comportamento e também
no seu pensamento é essas substâncias
existentes continuam a ser fabricada de
multiplicados na atualidade
vivemos tempos diferentes daquilo que se
passava por exemplo os acusados no
século 19 vendia os medicamentos pela
indústria vai a uma biópsia é um dos
mais utilizados mais traumático na
atualidade com só por ser um medicamento
também nessa altura de distribuir
cocaína nesta forma interessante para
melhorar a vida das pessoas o papa leão
13 13 foi o último jogador conhecido eu
de mariana é uma mistura de álcool
cocaína e que foi muito difundido é a
inclusivamente um álbum mariani que foi
ensinado não só parece papa mas também
por muitos outros empreendedores e 10
pés
portanto o uso de cocaína esta é uma
espécie de bula do medicamento que é é a
coca cola
na américa do norte em particular eu
estávamos mais de 70 produtos para city
como este era um feto de cão é extratos
de cocaína eram estimulantes como dizem
está convencionado quer dizer que
vivemos tempos de grande difusão das
drogas sem que daí decorrentes nenhum
problema particular e que isso causasse
carlito é com certeza que havia pessoas
questionavam dependente também nessas
alturas mas sem que isso causasse um
alarme social e se determinada altura
particularmente na américa do norte há
um movimento de grande esperança cristã
quer dizer grande tentativa de mudar os
comportamentos dos outros é é um
movimento no setor é americano
conservadora extremista que entende os
alunos que fez como queria acabar com ó
com as todas as substâncias que pudessem
ser usadas pelas populações e como viram
eram bastante
é essa esses movimentos sociais com uma
outra pessoa passar talvez mais
simpática campeonatos mais humanitária a
preocupação com saúde das populações
sendo que nessa altura muita gente
sobrevive à fábrica da promoção
industrial através do uso de álcool éter
e todas as outras substâncias e portanto
um humanismo e repensar essa idéia foi
levada particularmente nos estados
unidos
então na altura na transição para o
século 21 disse que seria entre santo
limitar os introduzindo aí uma dimensão
quase sempre não existente que é o
direito a olé
a proibição é entrevistar estados unidos
com um bicho passou à frente do bispo
grande dinamismo uma conferência
internacional com 13 países onde está
portugal em xangai e outra em 1912 e
muita hesitação
muita discussão entre aqueles que criam
é cavar com todas as drogas chamadas
também como idealistas e que os mais
realistas que achavam que as drogas
fazem parte da vida da humanidade e que
talvez não fosse tão inclusivo assim
intransitáveis dessa maneira tão grupo
thá é essa luta vai me dizer que em seus
venceram nos dividir e portanto a partir
daí criança que o que nós temos é apenas
a cesárea uma proibição a intervenção do
comércio do fabrico de todas as drogas
como narra melhor dito e algumas das
drogas que nós decidimos que deveriam
estar excluídas essas drogas apenas a
excluir um local e tabaco não é também
uma droga que facilmente podemos colocar
como isso vem e todas as outras passarão
a ser interditadas
a menos que fossem para os médicos e
científicos de considerados acima de 3
o trabalho de casa nesses países e deus
que posteriormente abriram estas
convenções internacionais foi lento
apenas nos anos 20 é que os países
começaram em transitar efetivamente o
uso de substâncias e tanto com a todo o
movimento século 20 as guerras set não
foi sequer uma situação de grande relevo
porém os anos 60 e pela então o
movimento hippie equipamento contestação
social como de repente percebemos que
era um jovem da nossa idade precisamento
que usavam drogas de classe média e
suscitou sobremaneira os puder e quiser
me diferencia a primeira visita é talvez
seja apenas uma metáfora mas a meta é
fechar o norte-americano ultra
conservadora decretou a primeira guerra
guerra às drogas é é é inimiga das
sociedades atuais que nós temos que
destruir até a primeira vez que se
declara mais países novamente declarou
guerra aos olhos é que ana clara guerra
ao químico e essa guerra aumenta
exponencialmente é os meios e os
recursos colocados ao dispor dessa
guerra que ainda não foi decorado
nenhuma injustiça pois possui
continuamos em guerra
todo dia nos últimos anos o quadro dos
20 ou 30 são profícuos em posições
públicas não propriamente de setores
radicais mas os setores
vamos dizer do centro das políticas do
do governo mas vários países a dizer que
esta guerra é uma guerra perdida causa
problemas causa maior causa muita
corrupção causa congestionamento dos
tribunais sobre a votação de prisão
antes atentado aos direitos individuais
dos consumidores alguns países e muitas
posições públicas do brasil em portugal
apenas os políticos conquistaram esta
ideia nós podemos vender mais
vencer esta guerra então começaram a
surgir as grandes opções que temos em
matéria de política de drogas
basicamente a questão da regulamentação
do consumo ea outra é que nós podemos
reduzir os consumos provocando os
consumidores grandes opções nos
perguntaram se devemos tratar as pessoas
têm dependência de substâncias
provavelmente seremos todos acordo pelo
menos conseguimos efetivamente tratá las
com efetividade
dizemos que podemos prevenir o consumo
também provavelmente estaremos todos de
acordo que sim eventualmente com exceção
de alguns setores e mais extremistas
também são atingidos
é questão é é com o jurídico aqui em
primeiro primeira cena a regulamentação
que nós já sabemos sobre isso primeiro
preciso uma questão de legitimidade a
discutir é o legítimo proibir uso de
determinadas drogas e outras prometeu as
estancadas as próximas vítimas pensar em
ficar sem nós sabemos já muitos anos
porque há experiências diversas isto vão
também a existência de vários tipos de
regulamentação
provavelmente todos ouviram falar de
coffee shops holandeses podem tomar
algumas das substâncias
uma das substâncias tóxicas na verdade é
também ler-se estado dos estados unidos
da américa a 0 o santos tenta
descriminalizar a maria joana que a
forma não se tratam os canais na américa
do norte é também mostrar a ter
movimentos assim e agora portugal também
foi muito inovador e descriminalizou no
ano 2001 todas as drogas e portanto elas
deixaram de ser consideradas crime
o seu uso de drogas o que implica de
algum modo já temos algum conhecimento
todas as suas experiências e também já
temos comparações e estudos científicos
do país mais precisas e menos
compreensíveis e chegar a uma conclusão
nós podemos prescindir de considerar
cremos drogas sem que daí decorre há
nenhuma derrogação no consumo 10 pontos
ante o que é uma boa possibilidade está
agora até ser levantado porque há países
inclusivamente o melhor estado já
legalizaram o uso de algumas substâncias
começando com o colorado com o estado
precisa estar somente a outros que já
fizeram esse movimento quando é possível
comprar legalmente e ter uma firma de
venda de kaká na verdade é mesma coisa
que propõe o uruguai já na hora
como o estado vai propõe se a situação
está é entende tudo
são paulo a parte dele com a condição
dos danos dos consumos e da vovó também
advertências sobre os riscos que elas
possam provocar nas pessoas é significa
estudar o modo que nós admitimos que a
opção acho que vão continuar a consumir
como parece que é um facto off e
portanto o que nós temos que fazer algum
modo a reduzir os danos das condições
a primeira e mais emblemática dessas
medidas é a troca de seringas
nós já temos em portugal desde 1993
depois do programa de substituição para
independentes ou piadas
depois todo o apoio que nós possamos dar
a pessoas que estão na rua e que estão
em sérias dificuldades com seus drogas e
já agora também estou honrado por ter
sempre procuramos fazer junto dos
consumidores que efetivamente consomem
drogas entre os quais curiosamente
também são alguns estudantes
universitários
tudo que puder ser é advertência para os
riscos cuidado com o uso e redução da
idade
tudo isto é necessária ou e todos os
tipos de medidas tem uma eficácia
obviamente não absoluta mas é importante
na redução dos danos na proteção dos
consumidores e portanto nós precisamos
desse tipo de emergência
em portugal apenas uma das medidas
previstas nunca foi implementada é uma
questão em aberto na sociedade são as
chamadas alas consumir vigiado tiram
consumidor sem dogmas droga estava em um
sítio seguro quanto possam injetar a
substância que desejam consumir
existem muitas vezes em outros países
designadamente espanha apresenta a
importância de sinalizar a importância
da ansiedade durante os últimos anos em
portugal quer apenas o indicador se da
descida não se transmite por tomar
drogas transmitir troca materiais de
injeção de sangue
o que aconteceu é que em portugal nos
últimos 30 anos
uma pequena parcela da população
seguramente muito menos do que meio por
cento da população são os consumidores
enganados drogas chegaram a ser durante
vários anos mas pessoas infectadas e
mais pessoas a morrer por cida do que os
outros 10 milhões e meio o que significa
traduzido em números trágicos como eram
mais de 4.000 tóxico internet após a
infecção em 64 mil pessoas
talvez algumas delas pudessem ser tóxico
dependentes hoje mas poderia estar vindo
a encolher deus e curiosa
portanto finalizando as drogas estão pra
ficar
parece até que se multiplica no móvel
com os meios de distribuição da internet
com o fabrico novas substâncias
precisamos de ser intransigente na
difícil arte de viver com drogas
[Aplausos]